she hit me in the face Ben Higgins this
season of The Bachelor promises to be
wild but how will then handle all the
craziness I put him to the test with the
four most intense personalities the show
is known for first we have the girl who
has the weird job hi Stacy
I walk Birds they think obesity is such
a big problem today and birds can fly
but who's walking them what if their
legs get so fat they can't even fly away
so it's why it's important to me
I love to hear more about it
all right next scenario we have the girl
who brings the weird gift okay hey
Michelle nice to meet you so uh I
brought this sign today mm-hmm
sign that you and I should be together
yeah yeah and it's black because if you
don't pick me it's the color of my soul
will turn your this is great and I need
to start preparing better for this test
can we also write something a little
lighter on the sign Oh positive spin I
love it it's actually an et sign number
three we have too much too soon girl hi
I'm Casey oh I have been reading your
high school yearbooks and looking for
your photo albums I called your mom um
and I just feel like you know you're
ready to be a dad so what are you
thinking five kids or 25 well Casey I
think you know you've obviously
committed to coming here so how about I
talk to you inside and I learn more
about myself through you been killing it
all right this is good practice
we had too much too soon now we have
children too soon hey Jennifer and
justly I'm really worried we're not
gonna have enough time the others like
it does mommy over with you it anytime
sing and this is remove all your
memories itself just be so horrible you
know journeys I get it and you know what
there's a nice couch inside how about we
take a nap round of applause for Ben
Sheldon get excited for this guy